33 during the pandemic some folks say
it's been hard to get dental care for
their kids the restrictions put a lot of
dental offices in a place where they had
to change the way they do things
our bianca holman here is live to share
more about a partnership
that's designed to help families get the
care that they need tell us more about
it bianca
hey good morning good morning everybody
at home we've been learning about how
important dental caries is for our kids
we've been hearing that kids have ended
in the er they're getting root canals
yes
six-year-olds getting root canals it's
unheard of dental care is so important
to tell us more about this program dr
tong siri good morning dr sullivan
so dr tom siri tell us more about the
liberty program and how you all teamed
up with unlv
so liberty dental plan teamed up with
unlv to
start this prevention clinic we thought
it was really important in this time of
need for our community
to allow access for dental care for all
children in this community because of
the things that you just said the
emergency visits and access to care
being limited
yeah so for kids five to eighteen school
age kids
this is a free program how can people
get plugged in if they're watching this
now and they say hey i don't have dental
care
i need to get my kid in this seat right
now how can they get plugged in
call us yes
call us uh the number 702 774-2461
please call us right away just like
voting
so please go ahead and um give us a call
or you can sign up at our the website at
unlv school of dental medicine
they have a link there for the unlv
prevention clinic so please
get access yeah all free and dr sullivan
we were in the regular chair you showed
us how to brush correctly in
circles but then also those x-rays tell
us about x-rays and we got our blue dyno
here
right so i would love to say that i have
superpowers and i can look between your
teeth and tell you if you have cavities
but in reality i can't
so i do need to get x-rays in there in
blue
got a handy dandy little x-ray right
here yes y'all made it so easy you guys
i remember when you had to go in the
little small room to do the x-rays they
are going to do this and this is all for
free right
yes and then we can just bring the
machine over oh wait it slipped out of
his mouth okay there we go
pop it in i'm earning my dental
assistant degree right now there we go
and we're just going to slip that in and
so the x-rays
x-ray is important so they tell us
what's going on between the teeth
unfortunately cavities are silent
they're not going to tell us that
they're breaking down and we can't see
between your teeth so these tell us
whether we
we need to fill something perfect so
again get plugged into this program so
that your kid can get those x-rays
we can make sure that they don't end up
with root canals and craziness but
you know again that childhood dental
care is so important because
uh we people see us they see our smile
well we got all masks now but still
when we're not wearing masks they will
see our smile we want our kids to have
that confidence and
develop those good hygiene skills back
to you guys in the studio
thank you so much thank you so much
bianco for telling the tooth
the whole tooth and nothing but the tube
john thank you nate good one nate the
whole tooth
there you go the whole tooth now